[Music]
[Applause]
frank isola the net studio host maybe he
can help us here he's also one of the
contributors to around the horde and
pardon the interruption
what were you expecting last night frank
first of all speaking of quarterbacks
yes last week you had tom brady on yeah
that's a great get and now this week you
have me i mean at this point you could
probably just walk away happy tom brady
and me in back-to-back weeks those are
two great gets by you dan outstanding
work that was a good interview by the
way brady brady's the warm-up act to you
is what you're saying frank you two
dashing uh good-looking guys that was
that was a good interview thank you um
who knows what's gonna happen with kyrie
there's always drama right dan you know
whether he's not playing whether he is
playing there always seems to be drama
surrounding kyrie irving i think the
nets are kind of steadfast in this idea
that they only want to give him a
short-term contract and how can you
blame them he's we know the numbers he's
played in 103 games in three years he's
missed 123. the guy just isn't available
enough so yes we know all about the grip
the big shot that he hit
with cleveland against golden state
we're now beyond six years of that
happening and what has he done since
then so
and he wants he thinks himself as a top
75 player that's all great you just
haven't played enough for the brooklyn
nets
all right it felt like a leverage play
when i first heard it i still feel it's
that way but that hasn't stopped the
media with running with the
possibilities here now kyrie kyrie says
hey if you're going to trade me here's
six teams here then there's the kd
portion of this separate fact from
fiction here well it's interesting so
you know kevin durant kind of following
draymond green considers himself new
media and he actually released a podcast
just this morning where he kind of
addressed the stuff the problem is
you know no one whoever was doing the
interview didn't ask him specifically if
kyrie irving were to leave would you ask
the nets to be traded that
so new media old media like you and i
would have asked that direct question
that would have been better off but i
don't the way that he answered the
questions and the way that he spoke
about it leads me to believe that that
kevin durant wants kyrie there but don't
necessarily attach my future to what he
might do so i think this is come on
josiah the owner sean marks the general
manager these had these discussions have
to take place with kevin durant in mind
he's already committed here's the thing
dan he's already committed four years to
this organization so one of the i said
it before one of the most underrated
stories in the nba last year was that
kevin durant signed up for four more
years so if the nets can do something if
kyrie's back i'm sure kevin durant's
gonna be happy with that i think if they
can get something for kyrie irving i
think kevin durant's going to think
let's go game on let's play
when it comes to kyrie
i say never say never because i he's a
wild card that i don't know if he just
says hey you know what i'm going to go
play for the lakers for six million
dollars i know and the the other
variable there is now he's using i
believe it's his uh former stepmom as
his age and i don't know what kind of
experience she has but a lot of times
this is when you do need an experienced
agent whether you know a man or a woman
that has connections around the league
where you know if you make one
his agent is his former stepmom yes
exactly
and here's what and you remember this
dan from years ago once you get family
members involved remember with mark
messier's negotiations with the new york
rangers he had his dad and his brother
negotiating for him and then all of a
sudden when you know the rangers are
saying certain things that he's getting
up there in age he looks a little slow
they take it personally they don't take
it as business so you always have to
factor that in as well but i think
you're absolutely right if kyrie would
have turned down the 36 million and take
six million we would all say you crazy
for doing that but guess what he's so
unpredictable that it wouldn't be the
craziest thing if he did it but let's
look at the teams that he put out there
let's just be fair to what has been
reported
the team that makes the most sense for
kyrie and makes the most sense for that
team
is which scenario well i would say
probably the lakers just because you
have anthony davis there and you do have
lebron and he's one with lebron he needs
to go to a team where he's not going to
be the best player he was the best
player for a while in cleveland they
weren't any good he was the best player
before jason tatum emerged in boston and
you know they did better without kyrie
than they did with him so i would say
the lakers i still think the best
situation for him is brooklyn remember
joe harris is going to be coming back
that's a great shooter ben simmons i
don't know what to expect out of him but
he is talented let's face it he could he
can defend he could rebound i still
think that's the best place for him one
of the teams that you have to laugh
he throws the philadelphia 76ers in
there we all know that he and james
harden had a big time falling out it's
almost kyrie's way of trying to spin the
story no see i want to go to
philadelphia you guys were all saying
that i didn't get along with james
harden come on now we all know they
didn't get along with james harden but
it all makes sense he spends a lot of
time in l.a she got the two la teams
philly's close to west orange new jersey
where he lives obviously the knicks are
close and then you have you know dallas
with mark cuban with deep pockets and
then everybody wants to go to miami so
all the teams make sense from that
standpoint
all right
recap what the knicks did
well the knicks did a lot of maneuvering
a lot of future picks you know it's
funny when oklahoma city collects picks
everyone is saying wow look how smart
they are and the knicks do it i think
because people are judging it on their
past thinking somehow they'll screw it
up to me it's clear that they're trying
to get money here to sign jalen brunson
and we all know the relationship leon
rose the gm of the president of the
knicks represented
jalen
leon's son now representative rick
brunson is jalen's dad the knicks just
hired rick brunson tom thibodeau knows
jaylen brunson so it's all somehow
connected
and i don't know how the dallas is never
going to be able to prove tampering
because somehow they're all they're all
related to jalen somehow but i think
they're doing this to clear cash face so
one thing is if you could have drafted a
player a point guard you're getting them
on a rookie deal now you're going to be
giving upwards of you know 20 plus
million dollars to a player who i think
is good the kid wins he's a leader he's
tough he's strong he's gotten better
every year i don't think it's the worst
thing that the knicks did
you tweeted out this morning at 8 46 or
was that last no last night the next
knicks aren't giving up on produce jaden
ivy yeah maybe difficult to pull off but
it ain't over yet where do we stand this
morning at 10 31 eastern it it's over
now and that's what they were hoping to
do
was where they were going to draft they
were going to try to move players around
to try to get down to jade and ivy and
that's the thing if they had drafted him
if they
were able to move down and get him then
this whole thing about getting jaylen
brunson it would still be in play but
not to the degree that it is now because
when you don't draft anybody and you
were a lottery team last year you have
to be making some big moves but we know
how it works dan i mean come on they
they have to believe that they have a
really strong chance of getting jalen
brunson why else would they be doing all
this
you're right about you know the knicks
or stockpiling draft picks oklahoma city
i but i have more confidence in oklahoma
city because sam presti there's a better
history there that's right the knicks
might be doing it but
it's another it's one thing to have
draft picks it's another thing what do
you do with the draft picks cleveland
had draft picks for years and they were
horrible at drafting yeah
and sam presley's done a brilliant job i
mean you know he drafted three mvps you
know kevin durant you know when i could
have drafted him i get that but james
harden russell westbrook serge ibaka the
kid josh giddy that they have now but
remember this too when you have all
those draft picks you can then attach
draft picks with players so for example
let's say there was a team out there
that might be willing to take julius
randle and you add in a draft pick maybe
you could take a good player back when
good players become available a lot of
time a lot of times
teams are saying well we're going to
rebuild what do you have well now the
knicks have all these draft picks to
offer again i don't i don't think it's
the worst thing to have that many assets
like they have right now
which team had the best night last night
i think oklahoma city definitely did and
i think detroit i give them a lot of
credit troy weaver you know you could
tell that they're building towards
something i think cade cunningham who
began the season kind of injured toward
the end of the season a lot of people
thought he should be rookie of the year
i did because he didn't play enough
games but you know they're rating uh
jaden ivey so i think detroit looks like
a team that's uh that's starting to come
up a little bit yeah i agree i i love
the ivy pick i've said it probably five
times this morning so i'm probably
overrating him but if you get deandre
ayton
you know maybe you start you got a young
team there and uh
you know it's tough sledding in the east
but i i like what detroit is at least
trying to do yeah feels like they have a
game a game plan i i completely agree
when you're rebuilding that going about
it the right way another team you know
patrick baldwin jr was a kid that was
coming out of high school in the chicago
area his dad at the time was an
assistant coach at northwestern he was
one of the top recruits in the country
he was injured did not play that well
his first year of milwaukee playing for
his father
and then he goes to golden state if
you're a young player
that would you know that didn't have the
greatest freshman year for whatever
reason and you end up in a situation
like that great environment great
culture you get to play with steph curry
clay thompson and draymond green you're
going to learn how to be a pro right
away i actually think the warriors
considering where they picked and the
fact that they're the champions actually
thought it was a pretty interesting pick
by them
you know the warriors were such a great
story this year but then the way they
acted after they won the championship
like this us against the world and like
like they became
dislikable yeah well dan come on you
you've been doing this forever every
time a team wins it doesn't matter which
team it is you always get players in the
locker room that say only the guys in
this locker room thought we could do
that no that's not really true a lot of
people thought that you guys could win i
was a little surprised i think that's
where we are
today with social media and so many
television shows and radio programs like
yourself
i'm surprised at how much the players do
pay attention to this stuff even a guy
like steph curry i was on the court
after the game his dad
mentioned how the idea that he hadn't
ever won
a finals mvp was wearing on him dan when
we were when we were covering the finals
in the 90s we never went into an nba
finals thinking i wonder who might win
finals mvp now it's something that we
actually talk about before the finals
even begin of course in the 90s we all
knew that michael jordan came in anyway
that's besides the point but it's these
things like i like did steph curry need
to win a finals mvp to validate his
career i never thought that but clearly
he did because he and then after the
game he brought up how people who said
that he was never going to win i was
kind of surprised at a team like that
that's
accomplished so much is so worried about
what people in the media saying this is
our job to talk about it yeah i wonder
if the uh mvp in the finals is an
overrated award from the standpoint of
you can have two bad games or you might
have three really good games
um
and you know
kd does kd win the finals mvp without
having steph curry there
um andre iguodala won the mvp
guarding lebron and lebron averaged
almost a triple double which i still
don't understand how steph didn't win it
that year that's why it's like it's kind
of tricky cedric maxwell wanted for the
celtics you know one year uh yeah thank
you you just have these these outliers
yeah and i think really what you're
trying to say is it's a bunch of
knuckleheads in the media voting for it
so it's 11 people it's a subjective
award number one and if you go go back
and wait it's only 11 people yeah so
this way it's an odd number this way it
can't end up tied now the most recent
ones have been 11 people voting for it
do you vote no
i haven't had a vote finals vote in a
long time i think the last time i had a
finals vote i wrote the words michael
jordan which was which was kind of easy
but you know wait you got stripped of
the honor of voting for the what wow
yeah it's not fair it's just not fair
are you okay
i don't know i don't you know the i'm
not one of the chosen and i was at the
game too now they would have had to look
to find me because the seating in boston
it's not like the old days dan we were
basically right on the court we were all
the way up in the rafters wasn't a bad
seat though you could see a lot one
thing about curry go look up his games
the last three games of that series look
at the numbers he put up it's almost as
if iguodala had a huge last game and
it's almost like they're basing it on
game six as opposed to all the games
leading up to that maybe that's why you
don't vote anymore because you bring up
interest you put too much thought into
it yeah you did
i remember when um
i you know i voted for the mvp i voted
for all the awards but um i remember
voting for jordan uh the year barkley
won i voted for jordan when uh carl
malone won yeah and so you would hear
from like a columnist would say from the
deseret news be like uh we want to get
your thoughts on why you didn't vote for
carl malone i go well the most valuable
player in the nba
is michael jordan
no matter what and he he's going to win
a championship
well you can't vote on what you think
he's going to do i go well i'm going to
michael is the most valuable player like
lebron has been the most valuable player
to the league with everything that
happens and i said i'm sorry i'm voting
for michael jordan
it becomes voter fatigue really yeah and
also it became for carl malone a bit of
a lifetime achievement award what i love
now voting for the awards and this year
i voted for all of them for defensive
player of the year bam out of bible you
know comes from the culture in miami he
said i should have won the award he
played 56 games we never used to even
consider someone for an award unless
they played minimum 65. he played 56
games and 30 should have been the
defensive player of the year draymond
green played in the 40s and he thought
he should have been first team all
defense it's bizarre how guys don't
think you should have to participate
like i said the nba should be the one
sport that gives out participation
trophies because not enough guys
participate i said to the commissioner a
couple of weeks ago you gotta have a
number here you got to have minutes
played or games played 100 to get to to
qualify for these awards
i'll give you you'll love this stat so
mikhail bridges led the nba in total
minutes played all right
if this were 19 years ago he would have
finished 37 in minutes played
39 year old michael jordan or has made
39 year old karmalone 40 year old
michael jordan played more minutes that
year in 2002 i guess that is or 2001
then mikhail bridges the leader in
minutes played played this year in the
nba i think we should do a podcast get
off my lawn
you and me i'm up for it will tom brady
join us every once in a while maybe
he'll probably turn it down when he
hears it maybe well that's that's that's
true i'm a good brady guy
frank thanks for joining us this is hong
kong all right dan thanks a lot you're
looking great frank isola yeah frank
lost his vote
like i lost my vote when i left the
mothership i don't get to vote on the
nba awards frank covers the nba and he
lost his vote for the finals mvp that
one is gonna hurt one of 11 people